a number of businesses just lined up
over 2 days to ask me questions they
range from $200,000 a year to $140
million a year and the crazy thing is is
the questions between businesses are so
similar that they apply to all of them
and we pulled out the best moments that
we think will give you the highest Roi
enjoy hey Alex thanks yeah you bet so my
name is Zach LaVine we sell Pain
Management Services to New Yorkers okay
um Integrated Pain so kpt um but like
old people young people women men it we
have a bunch of avatars right now which
is potentially a problem brick and
mortar brick and mortar we're out of
network insurance which is a dying which
we'll get to reason we do 4.2 in Revenue
you're mostly insurance or you're mostly
cash mostly Insurance oh mostly
Insurance out of network got yeah 4.2
want to get to 20 okay got it we have
three offices and don't know exactly how
to transition out of the dying business
model obviously our industry is growing
yeah so what business model are you
thinking about switching to cash
H I have a bunch of friends who are in
network and murdering it in network yeah
do why don't you get in network we've
just heard It's a Grind Comm you know
it's commoditized down the bottom race
to the bottom yeah why do you feel like
the wind that you have right now is
dying from out of network uh because
reimbursements from payers are declining
each year whereas inflation cost going
up um and because the amount of people
who have out of network benefits is
dwindling as well it's mostly just
corporate um and that's even declining
uh yeah they're just getting smarter and
they want to push everyone in network so
we're getting squeezed administrative
burdens through the roof with prior R
all this crazy [__] so this is a therapy
provider who bills Insurance he's
dealing with an issue that a lot of uh
out of network are dealing with which is
that reimbursements AKA what insurance
companies pay providers is going down
but inflation and costs are going up and
so that's squeezing their margins and
for this individual he was making zero
profit and so he felt like he needed to
change his model quickly and so
basically had two options you could go
Network which is you have guaranteed
customers but you're getting in a lot of
ways like lower quality customers that
you know government and things like that
are paying for Mass Market insurance is
paying for or you can go cash cash pay
right like you can people can just pay
privately for whatever you want and so
he felt more aligned with the cash
payment and so either way though I think
understanding what strategy is required
to win within each of those paths was
kind of the real decision which is like
what problem do you want to solve do you
want to solve the problem of learning
how to Market and sell customers because
that's what it's like when you are in
kind of the cash business right and if
they've never done that before then
that's a real that's a real Beast to get
over on the other hand if you want to be
in network then it's going to be a
business all about operational
efficiency it's about Returns on Capital
and basically how efficiently you can
staff up and how low you can keep costs
across the business because you have no
pricing power right so it has to all be
off of efficiency and so those are
basically the two paths that he had and
so I wanted to walk him through the the
kind of the questions to figure out out
which of those he felt more aligned with
and it sounded like he definitely wanted
to go more the premium cash pay version
and so that was kind of the direction
that I let him in so you basically see
it as like I could either go in network
and then make your entire business model
around operational
efficiency um which is which is I mean
I've got somebody who murder it doing
that so I don't think there's anything
wrong with that um or alternatively you
just go premium be the best and be be
private right be cash by so the question
is how do you transition it yeah yeah I
think we've decided as a team
collectively we just don't want to be in
network because of the lifestyle you
know whatever I get it and who you deal
with yeah yeah a pain um literally for
you uh or really I guess for them uh so
fundamentally I think you just have to
think about this
as basically starting a business over
but with resources already you don't
really have to think about the service
you probably have to think about the
packaging itself so like what's the
what's the grand some offer for this
yeah um and you'll you'll have a number
of like you're you're just going to
become a normal business which is just
like you will run advertisements and you
will make offers to people and they will
come in and then they will take their
credit card out and they will buy stuff
from you um and so it's probably more
that it conceptually feels complex more
than it actually is and so it's probably
a ripping the Band-Aid off thing which
is that I would just out like so one is
what channel of acquisition are you
going to use I'm guessing right now is
it mostly Word of Mouth yeah it's
referrals okay business for a long time
yeah so um one is you can start sell
upselling existing customers so like
obviously they have what's covered in
from insurance but then um you know
upselling other packages that'll get
your team a little bit used to being
like it's okay to pay us that's from
like a really tactical level uh but from
an acquisition perspective you've got
content you've got Outreach and then
you've got you've got paid ads right and
alternatively you could have Affiliates
so we have to pick so of those four
things which ones do you feel like you
are better suited so from Affiliates
it's like uh go to shoot injury
attorneys or like you want to find the
the person that they're going to see
prior to hitting you we've tried a bunch
of that and the issue there is that they
want to sent in network or if you're
injury attorneys to workers comp cases
which don't pay very well so so you
don't want to go from that perspective
so you don't want to do Affiliates
content probably in my opinion probably
isn't the the the best way um so then
you have Outreach and you've got paid
ads I'm going to bet paid ads is going
to be your better bet since it's local
it's pretty straightforward um
operationally it's not complex like
running paid ads in a local area is like
pretty easy um you drop a pen you do you
say we need more like so obviously we
have a bunch of different types of
avatars so like really now like how
would you say going about you're
probably going to end up finding that
you have one to three offers that
actually convert and then the remainder
of your business will be upselling and
cross- selling when they walk in the
door so instead of thinking about your
businesses having like you know we have
15 Services we advertise all 15 you're
going to have one to three that convert
really profitably on the front end and
then the remainder of your business is
cross selling and upselling so it's like
you're going to have the most efficient
door into your business and then you'll
end up just cross selling and upselling
people and retaining people from from
from there and so like in terms of next
steps it's you need to record an actual
ad for an offer and then put it on meta
and then drop a pin on the map and do a
10 mile radius hopefully all three are
close together and you'll run the ad
that'll then go to either a CRM or if
you're low Tech you can just go to
Google Sheets and then you can have your
front desk call them within 60 seconds
and then if they don't pick up call them
again and get them booked because your
time is valuable you'll probably want to
consider running some sort of Highly
discounted assess on the front end so
that' be like a
$200 yeah x-ray or something like that
that they can get for 19 or 20 you don't
care about that you just want a credit
card on file so that when they walk in
the door you have two things one is that
when they walk in the door uh well one
you you want them to walk in the door
because they paid two you can charge a
no- show fee if you want to um but
typically if you're getting even a low
ticket amount you'll be in the 70 to 80%
sh rate so you won't waste uh so pay up
front actually put out their credit card
yeah yeah okay and just for the for the
discount offer now when they come in the
door you'll do the assessment and then
after the assessment you don't treat
them you'll do the sale appointment then
you sell at point of greatest need not
point of greatest satisfaction so at
that point is when you'll make the offer
um and then you'll be like hey awesome
do you want to use the card we have on
file because you already have it on file
because you got it earlier and makes so
much smoother sale so the issue he's
dealing with that he's at he's at
optimized stage he's 20 to 49 in terms
of his headcount and the issue number
one that he has is that he can't hire
higher level talent because they expect
full compensation and he basically has
very little cash to bring in the talent
that He needs right so that's number one
issue that he's dealing with um he's
spending money to grow but he's not
growing money's missing and so that's an
issue that he's dealing with in finance
because he has so many kind of products
and services the Improvement between
those things has gone down and ads
aren't converted basically he doesn't
have any real ads or real way of getting
customers in and so costs are going up
right and so these are the issues he's
dealing with which is really common at
this stage now let's look at what he has
to probably do in order to improve it
and so he has to create customer
segmentation by cohort and activation
process and then install sales training
uh for his team so that he can start
segmenting people and upselling them
down a customer Journey path instead of
marketing all of these different
products he basically needs to make one
or two or three entrance points in the
business then cross sell and upsell all
of these additional services that might
not convert as well in the front end but
work very well for continuity or for
upsells and down or even high ticket up
sales on the back end and so he
basically has to shift his perspective
from somebody who builds Insurance
that's just like whatever they take off
the menu you know because Insurance
encourages people to be like here's all
the different services and this is what
we pay for them and so people just try
and offer lots of stuff once you have a
cash business it's all about efficiency
of acquisition you're trying to acquire
customers as profitably as possible and
then Ascend them to the highest LTV and
so this is basically what he has to
build is the sales system the uh the ad
assembly process to increase the volume
of people coming in segment the
customers and then learn to head hunt
higher level roles once he increases the
cash flow got it does that help yeah
definely that's what you have to do like
you you have to learn how to acquire
customers that are cash based and so
that means that you have to run ads and
you have to sell [__] what would you do
like if you were saying from a strategy
standpoint like we have the current
business that's doing 4.2 million in
Revenue you're going to keep that
business but your all of your
discretionary resources are going to go
towards this if you want to build build
a bridge to tomorrow yeah should we do
any of the more on the things that are
still working within out ofet networ
like it's really just a you know we have
limited resources how much should we
spend on each profit we're basically at
zero oh [__] yeah it's part of the
problem yeah we waited yeah we wait
longer than yeah yeah I understand
because you can't control how you're
reimbursed no but we can remove the
lowest reimbursement reimbursing
patients which is like remove Medicare
then we can lower our cost structure we
could go that route I think that would
probably be the first thing that I would
do and then you cash flow so yeah you
you use the resources in terms of time
and money to build the bridge that make
sense yeah thanks a lot Alex yeah you
bet so all of these things are on The
Graduate list at this stage and that's
because businesses behave in patterns by
the way as a free gift for you if you
like this scaling roadmap and would like
to know where you're at you can go to
acquisition. roadmap uh and plug in
information and it'll spit it out for
you exactly where you're at don't worry
it's absolutely free so go enjoy it um
if you want my team's actual help on the
thank you page you can schedule a call
and we'll see see if we can help you out
hey Alex uh my name is Henry I sell uh
education I teach people how to fix and
flip uh mainly the Hispanic market so
it's only in Spanish uh we did 1.3 mil
last year uh second year in business and
we want to do 3 million this year so
with the more better new right right now
uh we only do two events a year big
events 600 people and we upsell to a
high ticket uh 12,000 right and we
convert 20% of the room more or less so
that 80% that went to that room never
sees me again I never sell them anything
again okay and well that 20% they bought
my high ticket the mentorship is a year
sure and after that I don't sell them
anything ever again okay so uh more or
better do I just do more of these events
and like NeverEnding looking for new
customers for the rest of my life or I
focus no you're good you're in education
yeah and education graduates people
yeah that's how Education Works so if
you look at the education system overall
the way to create continuity in
education is just always have something
else to learn or to teach right like
first year now you're an undergrad now
you're a graduate student now you have a
masters then there's a PhD and you get a
second PhD like you just you just keep
you know people just become endless
students and so do you want to sell the
business eventually or do you just want
to make money uh make money I mean we're
not no it's fine no I prefer the truth
um yeah I mean the easiest thing to do
is just double the amount events you're
doing either just do you can either go
one a quarter or you can do two at
12200 and would you travel or just stay
in where I'm at in Miami is that where
you run them now in Miami yeah would do
East Coast West Coast yeah yeah maybe
Texas or something yeah okay so Henry is
at the product tie stage and the issue
that he's dealing with is that customers
have nothing else to buy and turn
literally right there first line and he
says it himself all right and so in
order to graduate he has to connect his
customer success to product and then
make something new to sell them which is
the backend so I recommended he follow
exact that advice um and create either a
higher level thing or if he wants to
build out a continuity that actually
sticks maybe considered down selling
something that's maybe a cheaper annual
fee uh for continued access uh to some
of his services and events but the big
picture though was what does he want to
do now if he just said I want to sell
this company then we have to create some
sort of Revenue retention so that it
becomes valuable but for him he was like
I just want to make more money and so
then the obvious answer is like cool
then just do way more and so instead of
just the two events on one side of the
US put two events on the other side just
like that you can double the business
with really no operational risk
whatsoever I mean you have a really
simple solution like just run the same
Playbook more
times if I would if you were like I want
to build a more valuable business then I
would say take the year to figure out
Revenue retention which is how do I get
these people who pay me $112,000 to pay
me another $112,000 or pay me $30,000
next year or even downsell them to
something that's $5,000 a year but they
stay right and focus on retaining that
top tier that paid me the high ticket
yeah but I think considering for the
model that you have downselling the
upsell um I actually like a lot okay so
if they paid you 12 maybe they'll stay
for three year three to five um just to
have access to the network and some of
your vendors and the stuff that you kind
of like provide um and I think that's
something that people would be far more
likely to stick with and so then you can
basically think about your business as
from a zooming all the way out
perspective is that the $112,000 is
actually going like offset CAC uh which
is like you could break even the $12,000
if you know that someone gets into a
$3,000 year membership that's pretty
much all margin that doesn't leave so
it's like that allows you to spend way
more than your competition because they
need to make money on the 12 you can
break even on the 12 and then you just
have the stack of $3,000 bills that just
keep stacking up that's like low low
effort to maintain got it that make
sense yeah it's good the nice thing is
that you're honest about just wanting to
make more money it makes this a lot
easier yeah yeah yeah don't say I want
to make an impact so big make sure he's
an education business and education
businesses graduate customers because
they teach you I mean if you do a good
job you graduate that's kind of how
School works right and so the real
continuity and education is just more
education right look at College then you
have Masters then you have a PhD then
you have a double PhD and then you're
just crazy who knows all right so the
point here though is that he could try
and build a recurring Revenue stream
from this business but in all likelihood
his goal was just to make more money and
so why add complexity if that's not his
goal so I was like cool just run more
events and do them in different areas so
you attract different customers hey Alex
thanks for everything that you've done
uh I'm James I sell custom Branch
railings to homeowners okay I we did 420
or so last year uh I was I've read 10x
is greater than 2X and so last night I
was coming to me again like do I really
just want to double or do I want to try
to 10x um and so what I want to try to
do is to develop a network of product
specifiers Architects designers
contractors that can act kind of like a
referral Network I want to shift away
from the minnows
and to focus more on whales we had one
client last year about $50,000 worth of
handrails and if I could get 10 of those
in a year then I would double Revenue
just with 10 clients so kind of what are
my best strategies to go about achieving
that so where did you Source the single
whale this year he found me it's all
inbound it's all through search okay so
SEO or PBC SEO okay I just started
Facebook ads about three or four weeks
ago they're going pretty good qualified
about half of the lead so far
so I would so if you want to go whale
hunting then I think your your initial
thought strategy of finding the
architectural firms and engineering
firms and whatnot is a good one um I
would probably try the Outreach method
um as my primary way because you can be
hyper targeted in terms of who you're
reaching out to and the the key to
making it work though is like what's in
it for
them to refer you business are you
asking me that that's an excellent
question Okay so Architects will
typically in a plans like if they make a
set of plans they'll specify what kind
of tiles to use and what kind of Windows
to use Etc so I've I've we've gotten
plans in the past where it's like it's
got the pictures from the website with
the cad drawings and everything on the
plans and so it's like how to persuade
them to do that kind of In Absentia and
I should also note that we ship
Nationwide so this is not like you know
a hyper loal are you shipping or you are
you doing installs or no no we haven't
done an inst are you just you just
actually we just ship product
interesting
got
it then who are the decision makers well
right now it's been primarily
residential is what it sounds like right
it's primarily home owners we've done
some commercial work you know but it's
primarily homeowners who are you know
looking for something different and so
it's very what I call intentional
inbound search it's like they're looking
for something they are deliberately
searching it out they find it you know
we have uh a lead magnet kind of which
is like 250 IDE it's SEO and I you know
yeah well this is a fundamental change
in business strategy so you're aware of
that so with that comes risk because the
highest risk adjusted return move or
lowest risk I guess is probably adding
like if I were like tomorrow what would
I do I'd probably just add PPC in right
now um because you already have
something that's working on SEO I would
probably see how can I get way more
articles written so that my SEO traffic
can go up can I tackle more you know
more keywords um that's like the for
sure will work and make you more money
play the going after Wales for sure can
make more money because why not add
zeros to things um it'll just be a
completely different sale and you'll
have two levels of sales so sale number
one is going to be for the Affiliates
and then figuring out what's going to
make it worth it for them and then the
second level is what's you know what's
the actual sale to the to the whale
customer so what James has is he's using
Affiliates to get customers which is
this is inside of the leads book all
right and so um Affiliates are
businesses that have your customers that
market and sell your stuff to them all
right and so fundamentally I walk James
through the three different ways that I
have found that work best uh for
Affiliates so who's the decision maker
with the
whales um like the final decision maker
is going to be is going to be the
homeowner whoever is doing the project
but so you just want bigger homeowners
the The Architects have the ability to
specify it and to put it in front of the
client so like we also did another one
which was about 60,000 for a guy that
was doing a development of airbn
in in Virginia he put up like six YT
kind of things and uh you know so I had
two B very big so both of them were
Architects that sent you these the one
was an architect and the other was a
construction company okay yeah so you're
going to have to go B2B Outreach is the
prime basically when you look at core 4
that's going to be your what you're
going to do and then they're going to be
your Affiliates and so the the
million-dollar question is what's in it
for them so my my proposition would be
so there's three ways you can do
Affiliates at least you know in the
world of Alex so you have they sell your
[__] for you and they and they get a
commission that's option one that's
typically my least favorite option but
it is an option option two is that you
give them some morsal of something that
you sell that they can sell for 100%
markup they could keep all the money but
you get the introduction this is my
favorite way of doing it the third way
is that you um allow them to just bundle
in your free thing with their services
know with architectural firms it's not
like they're going to bundle in a
railing uh for their serice but just for
everybody else like those are the three
things so it's like they bundle your
your basically your lead magnet in for
free with their thing they sell so it
makes it enhances the value of their
Revol package you give them the things
so they can upsell your lead magnet for
an amount of money that they can keep
100% of or they just sell your stuff and
they get a kickback is there a version
for this where they can just upcharge
like you can do a small portion of this
that they get 100% of 100% like I don't
think so like maybe some kind of
contractors or architect discount we
wanted them to be stupid to say
now yeah because like the generic like
you get 20% kickback is just like
everyone does it like who here does 20%
Kickbacks for anybody who refers your
business you can raise your hand I'm not
going to be upset okay and so the point
is is that and you probably no one here
has referred anyone else business and
because no one cares that's that's kind
of the point and so it has to be an
irresistible offer and so if we give
away the lead Magnet or some think about
it as like my CAC for a $50,000 customer
is the cost of the lead magnet and if I
close one out of three introductions
then it's 3x the cost of lead magnet is
my cost to Aire customer which is
usually pretty darn good so what I
outline with James is right here on page
237 is that there's three ways you can
integrate your product into their offer
basically getting an affiliate to sell
your stuff and so I order these from
easiest to hardest so first you can give
away your lead magnet with every
purchase so they just give away your
stuff for free uh in order to to get to
get leads right so they'll sell their
product with your lead Magnet or they'll
just give your lead magnet away but
either way you're not making anything
from it they're just going to give it
away second is that you can get them to
sell your lead magnet separately to
Their audience which is my preference
right you give away something that has
hard cost or real cost um and you let
them sell it for whatever and then the
cost to you is just the cost of
delivering the thing right and so if I
had a marker business right I might say
I let you sell one of my markers and
let's say my marker cost me0 50 uh for
whatever you want to charge for it and
they're like I can sell this marker for
$5 I be like cool you sell it for $5 but
I now have a contact of somebody who
bought these markers and I might call
them up and say hey you've got blue do
you want red and do you want green and
do you want black and all of these are
$5 now my hard cost is just the 50 cents
it cost me to deliver the marker and so
the question is what percentage of
customers do buy a blue marker byy the
other three and so if I found out one
out of two customers to buy a marker at0
50 cents end up buying these then my
cost to acquire customer through
Affiliates is 50 cents times two so the
cost of delivering my lead magnet is the
actual cost and here's the crazy part if
they go make zillions of dollars selling
your thing great it means that you're
going to make even more money upselling
your stuff and so a lot of people get
very greedy about what other people are
making off of their stuff just focus on
the money you're making whether the deal
makes sense for you that's one of the
piece of advice that ilila actually
taught me she said never count the other
guy's money um and it's a really good
piece of advice and I'll will pass it on
to you but it sounds like an
irresistible offer to the Architecture
Firm because they're like we can just
sell this and keep 100% you're like yep
just make the introduction and I'll
deliver that and then when you talk to
the customer you're like yeah I'll
deliver that here's one rail but you
need 10 more and then you make the sale
does that make sense I'm not entirely
sure like people would order the entire
project okay so it's not like you can
just like I can't just ship you a sample
and be like hey look here's a then
you're going to have to do the
commission B structure which is not my
favorite but um that's probably the way
you're going to have to do it so either
you can do the discount I mean I would
say guys I have 20% that I can play with
here so you can take all 20 and give
them no discount you can take a 10%
discount and then they get and you get
10% Kickback like this is what I got
I'll make it work whatever way you want
but this is my bare bottom price okay
and I think that's what like that's the
outbound strategy so should I then in
turn raise prices for direct consumer
yeah I love that okay
thank you
yeah love that for you the reason I like
that second offer because I think it's
very compelling now obviously the third
way you can do it is just get them to
sell your offer and then have some sort
of Kickback obviously many companies do
this it has to be very compelling
because almost every business I know is
like yeah I give 20% at least in
Services every business I know gives 20%
uh you know Kickbacks for anybody who
refers business their way it's like yeah
but no one does anything with that and
so it has to be enough that would really
change someone's Behavior so think about
it like this is that
the offer has to be good enough that it
changes what they do with their business
if it doesn't change what they do the
offer wasn't compelling enough or you
made it too hard right so it's either
make the thing better or make it easier
for them my name is Cody um I sell roofs
of people um we did 140 million uh last
year trying to do 250 million uh this
year trying to figure out how to follow
the principle of giving away more uh you
know guarantees and and bonuses when I
have such high hard cost yeah and such a
high ticket item yeah well what are
gross margins right now uh 40% gross
what's Net 10 to 15 okay got it um do
you want to sell it or do you just want
to keep it forever or well I actually
just sold my roofing business and now
we're part of a PE firm that that now
I'm directing that that entire all so
you the platform yes okay so you're the
platform and how many tukens have they
done eight got it how long has it been
since they started uh about three four
years um I I just got acquired 30 or we
just closed 30 days ago and now they're
trying to roll everything into my brain
brand and I'm chaos spearhead yeah yeah
got it okay so sorry go back to the
original question now I have like better
context on this so how do I give a uh
you know follow the principle of of give
away more value make the you know offer
so good it's it's you know you got to
feel dumb saying no when I have such
high hard cost I you know I can't really
do a money back guarantee I can't really
give away more than a you know a roof
well the question is is that the
constraint like is that the thing that's
limiting the growth of the business in
in my theory yes because if I create a
good enough offer then um I could roll
that offer out to the other eight eight
other brands and that would be the
biggest amount of Leverage that I could
deliver you know in the shortest amount
of time and is everyone insurance-based
that's why they acquired us because
we're retail and so so so you're the
only guy selling just new rubs everyone
else is doing storm chasing and damage
repair and [__] like that correct and
what they want us to do is bring the
retail model to the other brands um and
add another layer is we sell everything
100% virtually so no inhome appointments
it's it's all you know digital and so
that's what they that's the vision is is
taking that you know Nationwide
centralized sales virtually so you want
an irresistible roof offer the greater
the change the greater the risk that the
change doesn't yield the outcome that
you want in the business and so
fundamentally you're always making a bet
that you're going to get a higher return
off of incurring the cost of change than
it costs you to do the change right and
so in this instance he is now you know
30 days in or 60 days post acquisition
of his roofing company getting bought
with seven other roofing companies and
for them to try and combine them he's
the one who's supposed to like lead the
effort of combining all this stuff and
so the idea of like let's let's change
the offer the offer is one of the
highest leverage things you can change
but it also affects every Department it
changes how you Bill it changes how you
sell changes how you advertise it
changes everything right which is why it
can change a business overnight but it
can also destroy a business overnight
and so when I see a business that in
agre between those eight has $140
million in revenue and $ 30-ish million
doll in iida you're talking about a
business that's got probably 300 to $400
million in Enterprise Value I would be
very hesitant to immediately change
something that's obviously working and
so there's lesser degrees of change that
have higher likelihoods of working that
could still materially impact the
business in terms of increasing the
likelihood that it exits right and
fundamentally I'm guessing that's what
he wants to get his slice from
centralizing the sales would allow them
to decrease costs because they could not
have guys on the road it's just cheaper
to do it it's also easier to hire sales
people who are remote all of these kind
of Downstream cost savings the other
benefit is that when you hire remotely
you have access to a bigger pool so you
can get better salespeople at lower
prices who close more deals and they
could cut down all the the real big cost
for this business is sales people who
are unproductive all right so people who
are they're losing leads on people who
can't close and so by reducing costs
increasing talent and increasing sales
utilization all three of those things
reduce cost and increase Revenue which
could disproportionately drive iida
which is what that company is being
valued on and so when I look at that I'm
like this is a change that you have to
do in order to sell the company and will
result in revenue and E growth and so
let's do this massive change first
before risking the biscuit right because
we might just found out that just from
doing that we get a 25% increase in EA
and that might be enough just bringing
everything together plus adding the 25%
you're like you might be right as rain
and at that point why risk it I feel
like if I were in your position the
first thing that I would do would be
centralize everything first without
trying to change basically I wouldn't I
would take the model that I already know
works is what was your Revenue before
you did the before you were acquired
okay you're doing 20 so I would like in
terms of introducing levels of change so
this is actually pretty good for
everybody like I I will typically not
try and change like five things at once
and so you centralizing all sales is
going to get cost efficiency
improvements and you're going to be able
to have higher sales utilization so you
probably cut off the bottom third of the
Salesforce that's low performing that
alone might give you a 25% lift in
general because the best sales guys will
take more of the sales and you'll have
centralized all the costs like you have
centralized all the cost right and so
you'll have an increase in Revenue and a
decrease in cost that's paired that
would probably be my first step that was
part of the acquisition deal that's the
only way I did the acquisition is if
they were going to give me full control
and centralize all so but like I
wouldn't I mean I know the question was
about Roofing but like that's what I
would do first and that will probably
take you six months or more um
realistically um in terms of in terms of
the offer to roofs um an offer that's
worked really well in Home Services is
instead of being a money back guarantee
um I position has a profit guarantee so
it's like listen um you want your thing
to be on time and on budget probably and
so I guarantee that I will deliver it on
time and on budget or I'll give you my
profit which is 20% whatever and that
way it's like you're not underwater and
you still have 40% gross margin so
you're not really losing on the deal um
but then people are like okay so he's
got skin in the game and so that's a way
of closing significantly more deals
because the two biggest um obstacles
that well you would know this but in
most Home Services it's on time on
budget and probably for roofs it's like
and how much am I going to be displaced
how much it's going to interrupt my life
and so I would put my guarantee around
those items and then just have a
marginal amount that's back but it's
really just because all they don't so
the big thing just for every with
guarantees is that people don't want
their money back they want the roof and
so they just want to know that you care
enough to make sure the roof gets
delivered and so that's really the the
solve for the guarantee is it just pays
down risk of them not getting what they
want and so as long as that gets
accomplished you don't have to do it
with money back you can just do it with
some money back that gets him to say yes
does that help does thank you perfect so
he wanted a better offer despite all of
those improvements and I was like okay I
think I can I can think of something for
you so if you if you look inside the
offers book page 125 I talk about
guarantees and so this is the guarantee
formula and so whenever you're thinking
about adding a guarantee like this is
what I think through so if you don't X
in ytime we will Z like that is
fundamentally what a guarantee is and
most people I see a lot of times people
just say I guarantee it but that doesn't
mean anything you have to say what the
terms of the guarantee are on a timeline
what do I get if you don't perform right
and so with this business and some
people he like well I can't give them
money back guaranteed because I would
just lose too much money understandable
now if you have hard cost like he does
then what we can do is we can just give
something else we can either a lesser
portion of money we can give something
else for free and so the guarantee is a
consideration it's what are we going to
do to show you that we're just as
invested as you in the outcome being
positive right and so we basically incre
we shift some of the risk from the
customer onto us and this is this is all
you're doing as a business when you do a
guarantee is they take some risk of
buying and you're saying no I'm going to
take some of that risk and so sure you
can take 100% but in this in this
situation he'd be taking like 200% of
the risk basically he'd be losing money
right and so the idea is again you can
add stuff so hey if you don't get what
you want I can add things which is like
hey if you don't hit your goal I'll add
more time which does work as a sales
tool sometimes though in the actual in
the real world if someone's not getting
a result they're like I don't want
anymore from you I hate you right and so
it does still work as a sale but it's
one of those like mid right now
alternatively you can go the reverse
Direction which is take away negative
which is a discount right so hey I can't
give you all your money back but I can
give you back my gross profit or I can
give it back 20% or I give you back 10%
right these are all things that you can
choose to give back and the thing is is
it just shows that you have skin in the
game and all we have to think about this
is the point of a guarantee so I want to
make sure I'm very clear here the point
of a guarantee is not to have the
craziest guarantee the point of a
guarantee is to maximize net conversion
all right so we just need to increase
sales more than we increase refunds so
proportionally we net more sales and if
you can just do 10% back then that's
enough to change behavior and that's the
point like if there's no difference
between giving 25% back and giving 100%
back in terms of the actual performance
of the sale then give 25 and so you can
move what you're guaranteeing in order
to find The Sweet Spot and figure out
what's actually compelling to your to
your customer and most times the the
things that you want to guarantee around
are their biggest fears in Home Services
stuff it's usually be around time and
around budget right are they're getting
it done on time they're getting around
budget if it's other services it might
be different than that and so you'll
know your services better but you want
to you want to list out what their
biggest spheres are and then Crush those
with the
guarantee hey Alex hello thank you for
the content you create my name is m
fatel I'm the founder of Alan okay so
basically we sell tools to creators help
them make more money and we also
simplify how Brands collaborate with
creators okay you see tools like
software so software and ser agency
tools so we have a music label a Creator
Agency for big creators and then a
platform as well okay so I'm coming to
that just in a bit I know the focus
topic uh we made around 4.3 Million last
year uh and basically my goal is try to
get to 100 million right now the issue
here is what's the split between the
three in terms of Revenue uh 1 million
for the Creator agency okay 1.3 million
for uh the music label uh and then the
rest is on the brand side okay my issue
here I got 40,000 creators but only a
thousand are making money M right and
I've been kind of struggling between
going on a SAS model to be able to scale
because when I do any social marketing
we get a creator that comes on board but
they don't make money right away uhhuh
so it's not like you're you know and the
longer it takes you to recoup your ad
spend is not usually a good metric for
scalability so I'm kind of pivoting
should I go into a SAS model where right
whatever I make from the Creator I'll
just be like hey like just pay me that
price and I take 0% from you and then I
just charge the brands the commission to
collaborate with those
creators this way I can scale the
business in a much faster uh say the say
the last part again so instead of me
making percentages from creators yeah I
provide them the same tools that allow
them make make money and I keep 0% okay
but then let's say they have to pay like
20 bucks a month sure but then I still
make my money on the upside on the brand
Side by connecting them with these
creators okay so switch to a
subscription switch to subscription yeah
okay
um cuz now like I have 40,000 creators
who signed up but I'm really making
money off a thousand right and it's free
to sign up and you only get paid if they
get paid yeah so um you're in a prosumer
audience so if you look at like Shopify
for example um it's super it's if you
look at the amount of people who've
tried to build marketplaces almost all
of them fail and it's my opinion that
the best marketplaces do run as SASS and
then once they get to scale they can
they can kind of push more Marketplace
like shop Shopify for example like it's
29 bucks a month or whatever it is
because they know that the vast majority
like they make more money charging $29 a
month and getting 4% on zero for the
vast majority of stores but people
continue to pay for the hope that
someday they will make money um and so I
think the idea of switching to SAS is
not a bad
one uh I am concerned about the four
businesses that you have um so because
in order to Win It SAS you have to be
like all in on software and so the
alternative to that would be instead of
letting creators come on for free you
would charge them to come on which you
could do it has like a onetime setup fee
and then maybe increase the likelihood
that they win either path would work but
if the ultimate goal is that you want to
build a network of creators then you
want to have the lowest barrier possible
on the Creator side um so I'm still
thinking of a free tier and a paid tier
with some minor benefits but then if you
really want to make money you got to end
up paying subscription exactly yeah yeah
you'll have to play with the feature set
because that's always a a
[__] just the path of least resistance
to getting to 100 Mil yeah so I think I
think um adding the subscription for the
base and then still maintaining the
revenue that you get from the the the
sponsors make sense I would maybe push
back slightly on the hypothesis that
they can't convert anything because it
dramatically decreases the value of the
network from the sponsor side
what do you mean because some people
will pay for Impressions yeah and
so those guys can for sure deliver those
and so maybe there's like two tiers that
you can sell you have another product on
the ad side or media side um it's just
something to consider perfect thank you
that's you just validated my thoughts so
thank good just wanted to make sure I'm
thinking the right way no I think it
makes sense yeah either have to
basically you have to position his
higher ticket and do premium wake glub
on boarding and then select only for the
really good creators and that would be
like you charge 5 or $10,000
and you really get them set up or you
basically flip the other way go fremium
um and then it's all based on like
basically media Arbitrage where you're
just running tons and tons of ads um to
get people onto the platform and you
just know what your average revenue per
per platform user is perfect thank you y
so this guy obviously has multiple
businesses and he's you know sinning
he's doing the cardinal sin of uh
chasing multiple rabbits or more
particularly many women in the red dress
that being said I still wanted to help
and so he wants to build a software
company if that's really what he wants
to build then he's got to go all in
because if SAS is one of the most if not
the most competitive space that's out
there I guess now there's AI but SAS is
still competitive everybody you're
competing against has is typically very
well funded and also very smart and so
they're going to have significant
advantage and so if you think that you
can split your attention and still beat
them it's a tall order right and so for
him my whole goal is that at least he
had Clarity on what he needs to do so
that hopefully he get that business up
and running as fast as possible uh so
that he can basically shut off the other
things and go all in hi Alex my name is
Alex you can call me Alex Rodriguez and
from Puerto Rico see from Puerto Rico so
I'm a music attorney aado aado
correct yeah so what we do is we have
our constraint is focus yeah you think
okay I
have so at least you said it yeah yeah
so we have firm uh so basically it's
three businesses yeah uh but today
thanks to Ed and Sammy we got uh much
much more clear what we should do but I
would like to know how would you think
about this because the the law firm side
it's growing 20% year-over-year without
me actually doing anything just
redirecting people that comes to me to
my law um and right now it's about 100K
MH and then we have the
educational side and that is making 200k
and it's been stuck like that in the
last two years sure and we're building
you get customers from organic yeah both
are organic okay so if you don't have
money to pay as as a lawyer you go to
the educational platform and we are
developing a contract uh automation
software for big companies like major
labels or publishing companies uh so
right now the the product our software
our goal with the software is to sell we
are seeing that other that big music
companies are buying Tech yeah so
specific for them so they're doing
everything manually we want to sell that
but we have a cash flow problem because
we're selling to you know people without
a lot of money and the service size does
uh make money so our our our problem is
where should we focus yeah you're but
your what's what's monthly turn right
now on the it's on the soft we got 100
people and we only have 40 active right
now and how long you been doing it in
the first year so you've retained 40%
are they actually active though um so
they're paying the people that are
active are paying $3,000 per year and
there are only like four four four that
are paying 3,000 and then what are the
other 36 paying are paying 600 per year
okay got it he has a very classic
problem which is that you're good at
doing something and you have two very
different avatars and if you continue
down either direction you ostracize the
other so he's actually at the product
High stage so he's 10 to you know 20
employees between the three companies
the three companies that he has and so
the issue that he has to have is he's
got a niche down qualifi leads are too
expensive and the cap his ability to
advertise that's fundamentally his big
issue right and so he's getting he's got
too many different customers so we have
to Niche down his his advertising and
basically message the new offer which
for him was going to be the education
and the software and so the
million-dollar question for him which is
what forced me to say I think that it
made sense was and this isn't this is
rare for me uh but was for him to go
down Market which means to go for the
smaller customer that's more numerous
most of the time you want to go up
market and that's because those
customers can afford to pay you like
sell to the rich you know rich people
pay better solve their problems that
type of stuff I'm always always in that
direction but because he said that 40%
of his customers basically right off the
onset were still paying him a year later
to me that's fairly compelling that he's
found some sort of product Market fit
and so in hearing that I thought okay
well Best in Class is like 60 plus% in
your retention for a consumer prosumer
type product which is where he was at
which is musicians who like want to make
it in business but it's aren't that big
yet so to me that'd be a prosumer
somebody who's you know a little bit of
above a consumer kind of business e
oriented s gig is right and so the good
news is there's lots of them the other
good news is that there's new ones that
get minted every day and it's a growing
market so all those things are in his
favor which is again these are some of
the reasons I like that the other piece
is that he some of the old businesses he
was going after I think though they are
big I think they're going to have
trouble over the next years with the AI
stuff like I think they'll have a hard
time pivoting and so I would be at least
I would second guess going all in there
not to say you can't I would just really
consider it now the other piece of why I
like this is that if he can move his
Revenue retention up at the 12-month
Mark then he has something that will
just keep growing year over year over
year because getting those customers is
not hard keeping them is hard but if he
can keep them then he can probably blow
the doors off this thing especially if
the education can offset uh his CA or
cost to acire customer okay so I think
we we we chatt about this last night so
you have a there is no right answer but
there is a path that you have to pick
and so either you're going to be an
Enterprise company and you're going to
build only for that and I would say like
you probably will just transact on the
education side in order to fund this I
in general don't like this plan but you
could do this um because you'll be split
attention and this is fundamentally why
people raise money in software so they
can just focus on one customer the whole
time build the product and then actually
get it to work okay that's that um
because you said that you're retaining
40% in basically a
um prerish Market which is where you're
at I would be inclined to say that you
probably are pretty close to a decent
product um
so you probably have nailed something
there because keeping 40% of people one
year later
on you know whatever it is for musicians
that you guys have for contracts and
whatnot um you could absolutely go all
in on that and get that to like 50 or
60% and then you just need to have a
different acquisition system so you
probably just need to go spend money
acquiring customers and that already
cash flows because of the education side
and are the people who are still paying
you on the software also educ customers
or no they usually come from the
education or from my legal services as
well so I have some clients that be 80%
of the job here the million dollar
question the million dollar question is
if they stop the education do they keep
paying for the software yes because it's
a one time Fe well then that's what what
you mean the software is one time Fe no
the education some they just pay and
they're going to use the software as
long as they so the only thing that
we're solving for is revenue retention
on the software and so like Enterprise
in of itself is not more valuable than
lower Market it's just it tends to be
stickier which is what makes it more
valuable but if you can get a larger
Marketplace easier to acquire customer
to stick as well as a large Enterprise
customer you've got a gold mine if
that's true and so if you want to go
spend money acquire customers with the
education or media as your liquidation
and then get you know 100% like but the
goal that you guys should have is like
we don't care at all about the education
all of your focus all the profit goes
into just fixing one number which is
that you need to look at M12 so month 12
retention um and just say like okay
we're at 40 how do we get to 60 and then
how do we get to 70 and that's all
you're solving for because if you solve
that then the thing will just keep
growing and that's the beauty I mean
that's fundamentally the beauty of
software once you get it right is that
it just keeps growing thank you
yeah and so for me that was um I thought
the higher likelihood path and also
because you already knew how to get
those customers whereas getting Sony and
and some of these large Brands could be
significantly more difficult and so for
me I saw that and was like I think
that's the direction that has a higher
likelihood um of succeeding given their
goals infinite banking yes insurance you
have 29 agents yes and you're uh needing
to decide whether you need to be the
face and get customers to feed your
agents or you should go all in on
getting more agents and teaching them
how to do lead
gen yes cool um yeah
so do the second one do the second yeah
yeah it's it's significantly higher
leverage cool so basically so think
about this is what what problem do you
want to solve so either you say I want
to become a like you want to keep
growing your brand top of funnel so that
you just have more and more people are
interested in INF Banking and then you
have all these agents that you pass it
off to so that they can you know
basically transact and own the
relationship so that's like option one
um that is I would say the lower risk
path because you're already doing that
today and so how many how many is it on
Instagram that you do your stuff or yeah
all on meta and YouTube okay and we're
get in what's your
followership uh from that uh 15,000
subscribers on YouTube and 12,000
followers on Instagram and 6,000 on
Facebook yeah and what percentage of the
leads come from that stuff versus
whatever you do in
person 15% come from online and okay
where's the rest come from the rest of
it comes from referrals and networking
and dude get agents I don't even know
talking about for sure get agents go get
agents yeah I thought I thought it was
like you 60 70% of the business was
coming from from your organic no most of
it's coming from for sure that and then
the challenge with the agents we
originally it was all me teaching people
how to do that how to go go out there
and get business go Network go join BNI
Chamber of Commerce whatever that's what
works for me and then we would get good
people that were like hey I don't have
any network so I said all right and they
they asked where leads were and I said
all right so let me go create leads and
we started calling business owners CU
that's who I was selling to but they
were not showing up and they weren't
really busy whatever we were offering
wasn't whatever then I reread $100
million offers and $100 million leads
and I looked at the value equation I
said the best value I can give is to
Real Estate Investors so let me go get
real estate investor leads and then
we're calling them all day long and the
people that I'm hiring don't know how to
communicate with them properly so the
only they end up just setting up
appointments and then they hand them
back off to me okay and they're good but
I think it comes down to recruiting
people want leads the first go where do
we get your leads well if you say you
have to go generate your leads they
might go look at somewhere where they
give them leads so we started giving
people leads so we make an offer to
recruits that's good uhuh well I think
that one is you could probably just take
the existing brand that you have and
just be more deliberate about the call
to actions that you make and Bas because
like if you talk about high level
Insurance stuff that's going to attract
both people who want to learn more about
insurance but many of those people will
be agents yes and so I think if you
basically alternate the ctas you you'll
be able to basically I don't want to say
Chase two both you know both but in some
ways you kind of can double dip here
because as long as the content strategy
fundamentally doesn't really change
you're just changing really the call to
action then you can kind of get a little
bit of the best of both but I do think
that the big thing that you need to
crack is teaching them to generate their
own own weights like that is 100 like
that's the limiter of your business so
you need to bring them on and you need
to have the training system to get to
reliably get them to self-generate like
that's it like that's what you have to
do if you do that the sky's limit and
the 20 people that we have at of 29 that
are just simply coming in and cold
calling Real Estate Investors all day
right now that are setting up an insane
amount I think our offer is not great so
I'm going to the drawing board with that
but all those people now I got to go
teach them I'm just teaching them how to
cold call well they already are cold
calling right huh they already are cold
call they are cold calling now well
they're coming in I'm teaching them cold
call rather than coming in teaching them
to go shake hands and kiss babies you
want to teach them the highest
efficiency strategy for getting
customers so whatever that is so you can
just like whatever your method is that
you think that highest percentage of
people will succeed with that's what you
teach cool so whether it's shake hands
kiss babies or it's cold calling
whatever or a combo of both yeah or com
either way is fine um but like
fundamentally like look at the biggest
insurance companies in the entire world
they are that big for a reason and
almost all of them they just they they
are recruiting machines right like
that's where fundamentally because like
they're not a supply constraint business
like you can sell as much insurance as
you want right like you're not Supply
constrainted right like you're just
demand constrainted and so you just got
to get guys and then put the system in
place so that they learn how to sell and
then that's the business heard heard
thank you appreciate you yeah this is
why there's higher leverage of him
getting lead Getters than him getting
leads so this is the leads book 175 so
right now he's in scenario one which is
that he's getting leads right he's
getting customers and he's sending those
leads to his agents to close right look
at a much higher leverage move let's go
to scenario three where he spends the
same amount of time advertising but
every time he's getting lead Getters and
so every month he's getting more agents
into the business and each of those
agents are now getting money now it's
the same level of effort for him look
his line is still the same he's still
working the same amount every day same
amount every day but here he's got these
new nodes that are generating business
for him and so if you add up all of this
these are all the extra customers that
he's gotten just from this level of
effort and so this has far higher
leverage than this does which is why I
recommended that he start making ctas in
his content to both continue to generate
because I don't want to kill the
business continue to generate his normal
leads but also make it clear for agents
if they want to join him and gain access
some of the leads that he has um that he
can come in he can train them and he can
show them how to get the leads on their
own which he can benefit from uh my name
is Mike Nathan um I sell cellular
therapy in home to the old affluent
injured probably and athletic um we're
new but we've got a million dollars in
Revenue half at evida um we would like
to get the 25 million in home or in home
okay got it we consider mobile
Healthcare okay is it like guy drives
out or is it you sending machines RN
drives out gives you an IV infusion in
your home okay got it um we like to get
the 25 million we're built to be bought
we want to exit so we think we're on The
Cutting Edge of this what's stopping us
is my team is awesome
okay great and from the NFL to a lot of
great we have great business to doctor
B2B sales experience zero B Toc
experience and that Playbook we're
learning is wildly different we have no
idea what we're doing yeah so what stops
you from just doing way more of the
doctor
stuff um it doesn't it doesn't quite pay
as well meaning uh we have people that
knock on doors to uh orthopedic surgeons
who are looking for patients with
alternatives to surgery PT
chiropractors it's a lot of effort and
there's some that are going to refer to
you and some that just will not yeah uh
so that's our constraint in a one market
we in the Twin Cities it's a one market
uh play we know there are more people
looking for this
solution um so we want to understand
what the B to C is if we go to then
Dallas Philly La as we try to scale it
we're convinced it needs to be a better
Roi than maybe what we're doing right
now what you so you're making 50%
margins right so what's the cost to
acquire a physician cost to acquire a
physician M who refers you business cost
of acquiring affiliate it's often times
just it can be a physician so we don't
track it that way but it's um $500 okay
so it cost you 500 and then what does
the average physician refer to you in a
year uh in terms of business
6,000,000 so I mean you're getting 12 to
one there and you already know how that
works so like what stops you from doing
10 times more of that oh we you're
saying they don't pay well but that's
part I'm not sure you're we've went
through the woods and hit all the people
that are going to refer us the number is
not amazing or at least I just know
there's more there I assume there's more
there's got to be more than the you know
the 200 people we've hit in the like you
you mean you've only really talked to
200 in terms of like reach outs and and
or you have 200 who signed up as
Affiliates kind of thing I don't know
the number off the top of my head but
it's in it's in the hundreds less than a
thousand of B2B uh PT
chiropractors orthopedic surgeons we've
done that in the Twin C and the super
small people that have given us has been
some give four five and six some give
zero yeah do you have an active
affiliate manager who's like regularly
reminding them yeah so with so the way
that I think about Affiliates is um it's
basically a second tier of customer and
so you need to have somebody who's
regularly kind of like stoking the
affiliate fire to keep them activated
and continue to get them to continue to
refer business so I'll give you example
so there was a a roofing company for it
was a Restoration company um they had
one star star salesman and all he did
was he'd go around to other Tradesmen
and get them to refer them business and
so they would get a th000 bucks to refer
the restoration business business but
the sales guy got 500 for every time
they referred and so that guy all day
long was knocking on doors walking in
the front door with donuts asking them
how they're doing bringing coffee to the
guys and then reminding them that they
existed and that's all he did and so I
think you were getting you're getting
you're you're doing the hardest part
which is getting them to uh refer you
just didn't have the the consistent
referrals because if you had 200 active
Affiliates who were consistently
referring your business and most of
these Physicians you know especially
like GPS things like that like I mean
they see thousands of patients and many
of them could probably benefit from the
services you have and so the activation
is both getting them to refer
consistently but also uh percentage of
customers that they see that they refer
to you so it's kind of both sides of it
and so I think that the missing link
with what you were already doing was
just that the you didn't have basically
the continuous affiliate marketing
strategy to get them to keep sending you
business so that's probably like right
now today I would fix that first because
you already have the acquisition system
you already have the network and so for
me like reactivating that affiliate base
would be the first thing that I did so
this gentleman is using B2B Outreach to
get uh Physicians and therapists to
refer him business now the part of what
he was missing is if you go to 240 in
the leads book uh which is the
Affiliates chapter um I talk about the
launch and integrate model and so
basically uh right now he actually was
missing both of those so launch is like
you want to do some sort of big
promotion with them so that you get to
all their customers now they were giving
him like a trial customer and he was
basically not getting any customers
beyond that and so if he's acquired 200
Affiliates and each one of them is send
him one customer it's cuz he's he's
basically not following up with the test
that they're making like imagine if you
you know if you have a business and you
you have customers and someone's taking
you from your business you might be like
I'll send you one and I'll see what they
say right but it's a trial and so
basically we have to think about getting
these Affiliates on board is like a
trial but to convert the affiliate into
an activated affiliate right and so a
launch is step one which is that okay
maybe you succeed with the trial and
then you propose hey let's do some big
campaign to send a lot of your customers
over uh and then you can make money we
can make money everybody's happy but the
long-term goal is full integration right
which is at what point in your process
can we uh integrate our business so that
what you sell is merged with what we
sell uh so that we don't have to do any
extra work or remind you you just do it
on your own the second thing maybe
because you might just reactivate the
base and all of a sudden you're like I
got 200 guys for refering business holy
[__] we're at 10 million um but uh the
second thing I would consider probably I
would still probably Focus most of my
time on the B2B because you already have
it um but for this business I think that
it lend itself for what's the price
point $6,000 a treatment per treatment
okay wait so so uh the average doctor
will send you one $6,000 patient per
year when he said it cost you 500
they'll send you one patient
M interesting so do you have a process
for once the patient gets the thing
calling the physician up sorry say that
so like I'm Dr Smith I send you Sandy
Sandy goes and gets the well you come to
Sandy and Sandy gets the treatment is
there a cycle where you call back me Dr
Smith and say hey we just dealt with
Sandy here's some of her stuff uh not in
a medical term like we're not putting
notes back in because it is private for
sure yeah yeah but we do we ask for more
referrals there's a circle back that way
there's not a a a patient loop back okay
that's not true sometimes that does
happen excuse me it does that's not
systematized though yeah I would
systematize the hell out of that because
it's like hey you just sent me this
person like let me close that Loop for
you she's awesome we did this thing she
loved it by the way and then we have the
you know the opening to the to the other
like what customers or customers sorry
what patients did you see this week uh
who you think it would be a good fit
right and rather than saying you have
any it's which ones would be is the
question small training stuff but it
matters um so I feel like there's so
much on the B2B side that honestly
that's probably where I'd be ripping so
you would not go after a b Toc approach
like advertising online going uh pushing
in on a strategy on that it's not that I
wouldn't it's that when I think
about so this the difference in like
theoretical and actual like I would
given given the fact that you like
you're already running good margins on
this thing basically doing it and take
this the way I mean it completely
unoptimized like right now right and I
again I'm not this is not a a slight um
then I'm like there's so much juice left
in this thing I don't want to now start
something new it's like I barely got
this one going I want to like crush this
and when I when I'm like no we've like
we follow up with every single person
I've got a full-time affiliate manager
who steps by our Affiliates I'm calling
them Affiliates but doc you know drops
by the docs once a week just to remind
us say nice things hey by the way like
that is happening all the time and we've
already covered like literally Lally
every single physician in the Twin
Cities and I'm like okay let's go B to C
but if we haven't completely squeezed
the hell out of this thing and it's
already working at the level it is right
now with like zero like you're only
getting one patient per Doc it's like so
yeah so you getting B to B customer is
the same as getting one B Toc customer I
understand why you'd be frustrated
because you'd be like well [__] it I'll
just [__] I could sell One customer on
my own without having to deal with the
dock but the whole point is that like I
want them to be sending 20 50 a month
and they can because they have the
volume and I think that first one has to
be like a beautifully choreographed
experience because that first patient's
the test run for them for you right
they'll refer you one and we'll see what
happens right and so one it's like sy's
got to be blown away right she's got to
come back and be like oh my God that
place was amazing and then you also have
to go back to the dock and be like we
blew Sandy Away by the way um and so I
think you have to tackle it from both
sides okay that's what I would do
getting into the ad side you absolutely
could do it and I'm could walk through
some you know whole strategy there but I
I if if we swap places that's where I
would be focusing if you were G to try
to expand into other major metros in the
next 18 months yeah would you would you
have the BTC sorted out before you went
to the next Market or would you honestly
no if I Crush my B2B play then I just
run my BW playbook in B2B playbook in
the new market like once I find
something that works I just want to just
do more yeah pillage right on thank you
yeah no you bet now if you if there's no
way to do that integration which there
always is but if for some reason you're
have limited beliefs throughout the
world what you can do is basically you
have to pay affiliate managers to
consistently kind of they're kind of
like account reps and so they manage the
relationship with the Affiliates to
remind them that you exist and remind
them to promote your stuff and so if you
have a handful of good Affiliates that
can be worth their weight in gold
because each of these business owners is
is advertising on your behalf and so if
he has 200 businesses which is what he
said imagine harnessing the horsepower
of 200 businesses of advertising and
forcing it through one well if you have
that he's easily going to hit his $25
million in sales he just needs to
activate and better use the resources
that he has at his supposal right now
and on top of that he's already really
profitable we still know the model works
we just have to do more of it I'm a
father single father I got two boys here
and um oh my name is DJ kristoferson
there we go I sell People to People I'm
restarting my virtual Staffing Company
cool and we're currently at zero Revenue
it's just a matter of getting started
okay and so we're really confident in
that my question is on a more of a
personal one so I'm a single father um
in a serious relationship
and she's not a business person at all
very sweet and supporting but what would
you say would be some things to prepare
her for when it comes to so your spouse
or not spouse your partner is stopping
my my partner I mean she doesn't live at
the house yet she's it's long distance
but it's coming together but it's
getting really serious okay preparing
her for being married to a um type A I
think you should give her a try before
you buy yeah seriously how do you mean
so fly out out spend two weeks with me
I'm not going to cater to you I'm going
to live my life if the way that I live
my life the way this works this is how
it's going to be if you like that let's
rock and roll if you don't I don't want
to change yeah that's true that's
perfect
no I love it that's that's great thank
you crushed it I see the most important
relationship that you have as you with
your goals because your goals are really
just a reflection of yourself and so I
don't want to especially if I were
single I wouldn't want to sacrifice my
relationship with myself essentially for
someone else the recommendation that I
gave was what I would give myself which
is be you and if the way that you want
to live to maximize the likel that you
do what you want to do with your life is
this way then rather than try and
compromise where both people don't get
what they want try and see if there's
somebody who actually just like really
loves the way you live that felt like
the easiest first step is like just have
her come out and just don't accommodate
like live the way you'd want to live and
if she's thrilled about living that way
then you have a very high high chance of
this thing working out because you have
little effort you're not pretending to
be someone you're not you're not putting
on a show you're just being you and if
being you is enough that she stoked then
you probably have a good life ahead of
you now if she comes out and it's not
the case then at least you didn't have
to wait two years to find out after you
both stopped acting that this is how you
really are and so I see the goal as how
do I get as far forward in the
relationship as possible possible of
what would it look like if neither of us
acted and then let's just behave that
way and if it still works that feels
pretty good